[Music]
[Applause]
ross tucker host to the ross tucker
football podcast he works for cbs
westwood one part of the eagles pre-game
yesterday and uh also on the call
saturday connecticut played army on cbs
and then he worked last night westwood
won the ravens and the chiefs and i
think he was at a high school game on
friday night did i get your itinerary
correct there ross
you know what dan pretty good yeah man i
drove up i live in pennsylvania drove up
to west point on thursday obviously i
watched
washington and the giants as you know
production meetings all day friday with
the yukon and army coaches and players
but yes
i am an american citizen dan it was a
friday night so
i got in my car and i drove until i
found some lights i actually went and
saw army prep play but that's what you
should do in america on a friday night
you should find lights and go so i went
and watched army prep play i don't even
know who they were playing friday night
saturday did yukon army i drive home dan
i made my wife i got home at 7 15
saturday night
just in time to watch the penn state
whiteout game i made my wife stay up and
watch the whole thing with me
got up sunday morning eagles pregame
watch the eagles in the one o'clock
games drive to baltimore do the ravens
chiefs got home at 2 30. went to bed at
three got up at seven now i'm on the dan
patrick show
we have mad respect for you we do uh let
me ask you the poll question the two and
o team that won't make the playoffs if i
said uh broncos raiders panthers
cardinals
got a pick
i'm gonna go cardinals uh i would go
cardinals out of that bunch extremely
fortunate to win that game yesterday you
know dan i'm literally in the booth in
baltimore
watching the red zone channel as the
late games end and i got to tell you man
i know we've talked about it before
it just bothers me i mean at almost the
exact same time i watched zerline make
like a 56 yarder for the cowboys to win
and greg joseph for the vikings misses
like a 35 yarder and i feel bad for him
i mean he's going to go in that locker
room and there's over 100 men just
looking at him he let them all down then
they go on the plane
it just it still rubs me the wrong way
that one guy makes it one guy misses it
and everything changes as a result but
to answer your question
i just still think arizona's division is
too difficult you know they've gotten
off to a good start but i don't think
they're better than the rams the
seahawks or the niners necessarily
as far as the game last night with the
ravens and the chiefs when you looked at
that first quarter what were you
thinking was going to happen with the
ravens and chiefs
well i thought it could get ugly and
last night sort of surprised me
in the sense that i thought you had to
play almost flawless to beat the chiefs
right you know i thought the margin for
error was so small
but actually you know they throw a pick
six in the first minute and then on
their their third drive they're running
the ball all over the chiefs and for
some reason greg roman called three
straight passes from the 24-yard line
lamar throws another pick that one was
all on him
and i thought man especially when it was
35-24 after that catch and run
by kelsey but if you follow me on social
media and i know you do dan i knew the
ravens were going to win that game in
the second half
because they had crab cakes at halftime
i am a big believer that it starts with
the press box food you set the tone for
the organization and the entire
operation and at half time when they
brought out the crab cakes check my
social media everybody at ross tucker
nfl i literally said i expect a huge
second half here from the ravens and
they delivered it started with the
decision earlier in the week to do crab
cakes at halftime
you're sleep deprived you are
you you are uh is there a formula to
beat the chiefs
well so they did a couple things that
they rarely do and let's be honest then
if edwards elaire doesn't fumble they
still win the game you know bucky makes
a chip shot field goal and we're having
a much different conversation today so
you know it's not like the ravens
clearly got the better of them i think
one thing that is notable though is
you can run on them again and i think
that that is your best bet is to pound
the chiefs try to keep mahomes on the
sideline as much as possible it's not
just a time of possession thing you
still need to get some chunk plays you
still need to score points i almost look
at it dan like and i'm not a big tennis
guy but when you play the chiefs it's
like you gotta hold serve man it's like
you gotta score when you get the ball
because they are almost always going to
they so rarely get broken except i think
it might have been the last three or
four drives that they got no points
that's the biggest shocker to me because
it feels like mahomes and the chiefs
always come through in those situations
i know if the ravens not having uh a
star running back
i would just have an empty backfield and
just say to the defense
if lamar is doing something here let l
you can't spy on him and that would be
my approach is
let's just spread it out maybe have
another either blocker or wide receiver
and have an empty backfield and just say
to lamar go get him
you know the only reason why i think
they don't do that is because so many of
his runs
start with a fake to the running back
and some type of misdirection now
they'll give it to the running back
sometimes on those wide runs just to
keep the defense honest but you are a
thousand percent right dan what when
they're trying to get junk yardage when
they really need it
he is not handing that ball off i mean
he's faking it
wide to the running back and he is
coming downhill i gotta tell you you
know as a former offensive lineman i
love doing the army games on saturday
because i you know i love watching that
offensive line play but i'm telling you
you know my rookie year was 2001. the
ravens have the most creative and
entertaining run game i've ever seen in
the nfl i mean it is so fun to watch
they're pulling guys one way running the
other you know the fullback leading the
double tight ends greg roman their
offensive coordinator deserves a ton of
credit because it is it is really exotic
and fun
we're talking to ross tucker host of the
ross tucker football podcast also does
work for cbs and westwood one and part
of the eagles uh pregame for wip
radio
you believing in the raiders
i think you have to i was stunned that
they won that game yesterday you know
after going monday night game
that you know they had a valiant
comeback in the fourth quarter and
overtime a late game monday night goes
to overtime to come to pittsburgh
against that defense now they're
fortunate joe hayden was out devin bush
was out tj watt got hurt but i don't
care
and you know dan i mean i can't wait i
hope somebody
does a like an mvp front-runner article
this week or that that would be an
awesome like uh radio segment who's in
the lead for the mvp you know it's like
every year somebody fights to see who
can be the first one to start the the
mvp if it ended right now conversation
but i'm just saying it's derek carr i
mean he has been awesome in the first
two games against very good defenses
very good opponents in the ravens and
steelers he's been probably the most
valuable player in the league so far
okay but the reason why i hate these mvp
uh conversations because
last week it was jameis
winston that's why we don't have these
this early in the season i know we love
content i know we love to have who's the
mvp you know is it tom brady is it derek
carr
week to week
that's that's why we we had it jameis
winston week one and then week two you
want to give it to derek carr great give
it to derek park and then let's see what
happens in week three here i did want to
ask you about the cowboys uh
what stood out from from dallas's win in
los angeles
two things number one
and i said i tweeted this yesterday dan
i feel like we need to acknowledge the
fact it's been two years now
when you watch a cowboys game
tony pollard just has more juice than
zeke i agree that's why i wouldn't have
resigned
zeke
i mean dan zeke is better as a pass
blocker but come on dude we're not
paying guys like 15 million a year i'm
not paying him to be a if i'm paying him
to be a pass blocker that is money not
well spent zach martin is a guy that you
pay to protect
yeah so tony pollard uh i mean zeke will
probably be gone after this year they
can't keep paying him the other thing
that stood out to me you know where i
live here in harrisburg pennsylvania i
saw micah parsons dan play his third
high school game ever
as a freshman and he had like five sacks
and i texted the guys i know at penn
state and i was like this freshman the
end at central dolphin high school maybe
the best i've ever seen they offered him
a scholarship ban
after his fourth game think about this
though okay
he played linebacker at penn state last
week
demarcus lawrence broke his foot
on wednesday they moved micah parsons to
the end for the first time since high
school on thursday he had a sack
he had eight pressures the most buy a
rookie since nick bosa back in 2019 he
hadn't played the end since high school
there's no chance the cowboys win that
game
if he's not playing the end my guess is
they'll probably keep him there sure and
it's kind of funny because think about
yesterday micah parsons and adafaoway
for the ravens both rookies both from
penn state and right now they're the two
fastest defensive ends in the entire nfl
and they're both rookies from penn state
it's pretty wild
is james franklin going to be at penn
state next year
i think he is yeah i mean there's a
couple things there right so number one
are we sure usc wants him are we sure
he's the guy you know the a.d and by the
way dan i love listening and watching
because you seem to have better
connections and sources for college
football news than anybody else does out
there
but i i just feel like dan the ad
for usc came from cincinnati i mean you
know i mean it's like it feels like 95
of the time those guys end up hiring the
guy they know
and that would be fickle i was told
fickle doesn't want to leave the midwest
that's interesting
uh listen here's what i would say
i think penn state is a top 10 job in
the country and he's done an awesome job
he really has i mean franklin done a
terrific job what they had saturday
night that auburn game it's just
incredible
but usc is a top five job because in
california
you are the school and
there's more five-star recruits and
here's the other thing
even in the big ten east dan
penn state's third in terms of resources
behind ohio state and michigan and not
only that
you're always going to be battling ohio
state just to win your division
and your conference whereas if you go to
usc
you are the perennial favorite to win
the pac-12 to go to the college football
playoff it really depends on what
franklin wants if he wants to win
championships
it's definitely an easier path at sc
than there is at penn state in the big
ten east with ohio state i'll leave you
with this if the packers lose tonight
oh
do you want to finish that
or is that your answer
uh i mean that could be my answer but i
want to get off quick i know you have a
big guest and andrew mclovin perloff
coming on at some point but no in all
sincerity uh they're not gonna lose
tonight there's no way but if they did
wow
we would be having much much different
conversations about what's going on in
green bay
no matter what no matter how they lose i
highly doubt that happens although i
kind of was impressed by golf and the
lions in the second half against the
niners you know
golf is too good of a quarterback
in my mind dan for the lions to be like
a a two-win team golf's a good he's a
professional he's like he's a solid
quarterback they're gonna beat some
people i don't i don't think it's the
packers tonight though great just great
to see you get some sleep okay i will
i'm going right back to bed man that's
ross tucker
he was uh very busy this weekend host of
the ross tucker football podcast he was
on the call ravens chiefs last night on
westwood one he worked the eagles
pregame he went to a high school game on
friday and then saturday did color
commentating for connecticut against
army on cbs sports